the new president of the european
council donald tusk chairs his first
summit of EU leaders this week with the
spotlight on spurring investment in
europe and the conflict in ukraine while
he's new to his job tusk has taken part
as leader in more European Council than
orbit European Commission President
jean-claude Juncker and German
Chancellor Angela Merkel on investment
leaders are expected to call for the
creation of a fund by mid-2015 to
quickly mobilize investment in strategic
areas and to speed up the pace of any
relevant legislation they're also likely
to give the green light to the european
investment bank to fast-track its
activities from next month Europe's
Eastern neighborhood and particularly
the conflict in Ukraine will top the
menu for the dinner working session with
leaders to discuss the need to continue
providing financial assistance to the
government in Kiev the implications of
the crisis on EU relations with Russia
and Eastern Partnership countries will
also be addressed new sanctions over the
illegal annexation of Crimea and
Sevastopol are expected to be adopted in
parallel to the summit